alexis mans vous heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin sur rtl france alors
on le disait ils seront nombreux à venir
rendre visite à charles de gaulle demain
à colombelles deléglise les deux églises
qui représente la figure vol yens et qui
en est le legato légataire légitime ah
oui c'est demain qui est prévu donc
l'hommage à la mort du général de gaulle
mort à la boisserie à colombey les deux
églises
jour classée rouge par bison fûté
tellement va y avoir des poux de gerbes
de délégations ça commence à 9 heures
avec jean castex ura également anne
hidalgo qui sera là tous les candidats à
la candidature de la droite qui vont de
vos six passes et c'est un peu le
passage obligé et l'eczéma aurait dû
déclarer sa candidature il y avait une
rumeur qui courait alors non il ne fera
pas finalement arnaud montebourg voulait
le même lui à l'occasion de cette non
déclaration de candidature faire un mur
du silence il aurait peut-être mieux
fait de le faire hier le mur du silence
lors qu'il a déclaré de vouloir gelé les
envois d'argent western union ça a été
difficile pour ça remonte à da donc on
va voir un peu cette ce ballet des
politiques passage obligé en campagne
électorale devant la tombe du général de
gaulle où tous finalement se réclame de
l'héritage gaulliste y compris eric
zemmour qui était prêt à réhabiliter
l'héritage de pétain lui donc c'est
quand même une ligne rouge pour les
gaullistes historiques et on se demande
pourquoi finalement la figure du général
de gaulle est toujours là a inventé un
bien sûr la vème république alors au
delà de la figure de l'homme qui était à
héros de la guerre et qui a permis à la
france de sauver l'honneur il a été
celui qui a construit la vème république
avec monsieur debré et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que tous cherchent à se
raccrocher à cette figure inquiète su
être un président populaire même si les
parties après mai 68 cents sans perte et
fracas il ya quelque chose là de la
politique perdue finalement les adresses
des aventuriers du gaullisme perdu une
certaine nostalgie un bal des
prétendants à colombey alors qu'il ya un
débat le premier débat des républicains
ce soir et oui sur une chaîne
concurrente ce soir tous les candidats à
la candidature vont enfin se mettre
autour d'un plateau et parler de leurs
programmes quelques différences sur
ou faire des économies ou retrouver la
croissance de demain on voit bien la
droite embêté à la fois par la
candidature d'eric zemmour qui a enfin
pas encore officiellement candidat mais
qui a fait bouger les lignes et puis de
l'autre côté emmanuel macron assez
hégémonique oui au niveau des idées de
droite puisque il a fait le choix après
avoir été ni de droite ni de gauche
d'être totalement de droite et d'essayer
de traquer tous les électorats du camp
et l'air alors un bémol néanmoins cette
primaire ce congrès a permis de recruter
de nombreux nouveaux encartée au sein du
parti donc on attend de voir l'effet
débat télévisuel voir si de nouveaux
encartés vous aussi rejoindre le parti
clarifie aussi les positions gérard
larcher le disais c'est ni macro ni
zemmour il y a une une voie pour les
républicains eux le pensent du moins
reste à savoir qui peut être le meilleur
candidat et
pour qui voter bien sûr les
sympathisants et les encartés de ce
parti mais un contre feu médiatique
demain celui d' emmanuel macron oui
alors le président lui n'ira pas à
colombey il était l'an dernier il a
choisi l'elysée après tout c'était aussi
une des maisons du général de gaulle
pour une allocution alors là qui va être
sûr sans doute la gestion de crise du
coc vide puisque ce matin les écoliers
remettre le mas puisque ça remonte même
si la france un des meilleurs taux de
vaccination on ne sait pas finalement
comment on va sortir de cette crise du
coc vide mails macron est en campagne
lui aussi sans le dire après avoir fait
des promesses sonnantes et trébuchantes
à peu près tout le monde ça avait
commencé à marseille rappelez vous les
promesses de chèques ça continue le
chèque énergie et
et bien d'autres là on se demande
quelles vont être les annonces du chef
de l'état alors sans doute la gestion de
la crise mais aussi regarder devant et
puis une esquisse de bilan parce qu'il a
parlé à tout le monde sauf au français
finalement il a une série le ferait
d'ailleurs il avait dit oui en juillet
qu'il reviendrait pour dire ce qu'il en
est mais enfin c'est quand même assez
hypocrite de sa pratique du pouvoir d'un
côté imposé le passé ni terre jusqu'en
juillet 2022 quasiment sans débat
parlementaire et de l'autre côté
arrivées à la télé pour dire c'est super
ce que je fais merci des français bon on
verra s'il y aura beaucoup de gens
devant leur téléviseur ce serait ignorer
sa bouteille ce serait donc la dernière
allocution du président de maquereaux
non candidat a priori à priori oui
puisqu'il va se déclarer à partir de
janvier février après la présidence de
l'union européenne peut-être qu'ils
n'ont il y aura encore une déclaration
pour la nouvelle année etc et les me
voilà je pense que oui en terme de
déclaration et sur la crise sanitaire où
il va essayer de mettre la crise
sanitaire derrière alors qu'on est
encore de temps et aussi les esquisses
d'un bilan qui est nécessaire pour
qu'ils puissent lancer le choix de cette
date de mardi on l'a dit le jour de la
mort du général de gaulle mais aussi au
lendemain de ce fameux conte premier
débat pour le congrès et leers et c'est
voulu ces politiques je pense que si
vous lui ça montre une certaine
fébrilité c'est à dire que là on voit
bien emmanuel macron animal de la
communication qui dit je dois faire un
contre-feu sinon je vais perdre la main
où j'ai un risque de perdre la main donc
il va à la fois écrasé toutes les
cérémonies
à colombey les deux églises le débat de
la veille il sera comment se positionner
par rapport à certains candidats et lui
comme je le disais va asseoir sa stature
présidentielle en disant voilà et
pourquoi pas 50 plus après tout je suis
le camp de la raison même si tout ça est
très discutable son bilan encore une
fois il est extrêmement discutable
puisque les réformes qu'il voulait
mettre en place il n'a pas vraiment pu
les mettre en place puisque la gestion
sanitaire et bien on le voit elle n'est
pas non plus un grand succès malgré le
taux de vaccination malgré tout ce qui a
pu être fait donc on peut se demander
s'il n'y a pas là une fébrilité
justement à reprendre la main
médiatiquement pour relancer sa campagne
et il pourrait évidemment parler de la
réforme des retraites évidemment puisque
cette réforme des retraites elle est
toujours là dans les cartons pierre
moscovici dans le journal du dimanche
qui est présent de la cour des comptes
disait que la france devait être au
rendez-vous de la dette et qu'il faudra
faire cette réforme des retraites le
plus rapidement possible donc on voit
bien que ça reste là donc si ce n'est
pas avant avril 2022 ce sera juste après
les français n'y échapperont pas et on
voit bien que il ya une volonté aussi de
montrer que malgré la difficulté
sanitaires le président veut continuer
ses réformes même si elles sont
impopulaires et discuter d'ailleurs par
tous les partenaires sociaux donc ça
pourrait être aussi asseoir ce côté un
peu volontariste gaullien d'une certaine
façon même si jusqu'à présent il n'a pas
vraiment défendu une certaine vision
souverainiste ou industrialisés de la
france mais en tout cas on suivra de
très près cette bien évidemment cette
prise de parole du chef de l'état demain
et manuela commercial etc si votre édito
a pas retrouvé bien évidemment sur les
réseaux sociaux